I made the mistake of reading CNN a
couple of days ago and I I read a very
long piece attacking Christian
nationalism which is apparently on the
rise in America and then I made another
mistake I turned over to Twitter that's
never a smart thing to do and on Twitter
I see the same person trending for two
different reasons
one of the trends was Christian
nationalism the other one was she's a
Nazi and the person trending was
Republican Congressman Marjorie Taylor
green so I said well I don't that
doesn't sound right to me a little
skeptical of those Trends so I thought
we should invite haran to hear from
straight from her what she means by all
these things congresswoman green thank
you so much for coming on
thanks for having me on Michael so first
question Twitter is forcing me to ask
this
are you now or have you ever been
a nuts a national socialist
no never I'm relieved to hear that I
yeah that apparently they can label you
things you're not and lie about you and
smear your character on Twitter and they
think that's perfectly okay and this is
what they have done to me ever since I
became a member of Congress and I'm
really tired of it I I am I'm I it hurts
me it hurts my family it hurts my
friends and it angers them it also
upsets uh people in my district because
they share the same faith faith that I
have I'm a Christian and they also love
our country just like I do but no I
think I think the Nazis did horrible
things who who can identify with that
but that's just the name and the label
that the Godless left uses uh to try to
smear someone's character and so what
what when they're you know they call
everyone a Nazi like anyone to the right
of Hillary Clinton they call it Nazi but
when when they're going after you
they've been they've been doing it more
specifically they've been going after
you for the issue of Christian
nationalism and that this is the you
know scare phrase du jour so forget what
CNN says about Christian nationalism
what do you say Christian nationalism is
well I'm I'm a Christian
um you know I I I have my full faith in
God and Jesus Is My Savior I'm I'm not
perfect I'm I'm definitely a sinner I
know that for sure and that's why I put
my faith in the Son of God who died on a
Roman cross so that my sins could be
forgiven and that's the profession of my
faith I also believe that Jesus is the
son of God and I believe the words in
the Bible that's what being a Christian
is Jesus's commandment God's commandment
to us is to love God uh first and then
love people like we love ourselves and
and love him and like he loves people so
I don't see how this is a scary thing
it's definitely not racist people
includes all people even the ones we
don't like
um that doesn't mean that we back down
and Cave into their demands uh or or
what they want us to do because I
believe a lot of the things the left
want are extremely wrong and sinful so
being a Christian isn't isn't a bad
thing it actually is a really good thing
for for everyone uh being a nationalist
means I just love my country I love
America I'm proud to be an American I
I'm elected by the people in Georgia's
14th District and I'm I'm very grateful
and and humbled to serve and represent
them here in Congress but also means
that I believe that Americans
hard-earned tax dollars should be used
for America in our interests such as
securing our border making sure that our
economy is strong that our businesses
are put forth first not other businesses
and other countries I care about our
kids I care about our kids a lot I care
about our kids so much that I believe
it's imperative that we protect them
from the the Godless left and their
plans to to lie to the kids
um confusion confusing them about gender
drag queen and schools CRT racist
teaching and ideologies and I care about
our kids future and that means that I
think that our government should be
working for America's interests first so
I don't see how that's a bad thing and
actually Michael most Americans feel
this way most Americans care about our
country and are tired of money going
over to foreign countries and
never-ending Foreign Wars and other
countries borders being being cared
about and ours being completely
neglected so these aren't radical issues
as a matter of fact these are pretty
common issues well the way the way
you're describing it I think that pretty
much everybody in America could have
used that term Christian nationalist
until recent certainly until the 1960s
probably until later so then I guess the
question that's a good description of
Christianity good description of
nationalism then the question that CNN
especially is Raising and and that the
left is seems to be running on in the
midterms is
what is the relationship between the two
the between the Christianity and the
nationalism and what does it mean for
everybody else
well what that means is if the
Republican Party were really to strive
hard for those to
um uh ideas or ideologies or or or
um what's a better word identity let's
let's say that that's what the
Republican Party really cared about that
means that we would care about
traditional Family Values we would care
about marriage we would care about
children we care about doing things that
serve families that means we would also
care about people that are neglected
people homeless people people that are
addicted to drugs people that are being
affected by the out of control crime we
would care about funding law enforcement
and and making sure that prosecutions
happen not just not just allowing police
officers to try to make arrests but yet
these people never get prosecuted like
antifa got gets off people can shoplift
um like up to 900 a day in California
with with no accountability it means we
would care about truth it means we would
care about
um care about holding our government
accountable it means that means that we
would actually be serving and caring for
others and it doesn't put a race on that
it doesn't put an identity on that it
doesn't doesn't put anyone first or
second or last even it just means that
we will care for Americans care for
people here it also means we would do
things like secure our border that would
stop the deadly flow of fentanyl coming
across that would also stop the the
human trafficking that is very real and
happening every single day it would also
stop American cities and towns all over
the country from being overrun by people
who broke the law to come in our country
these are these are all good things it
means that we will take care of one
another and love one another and then
when you combine that with being a
nationalist that means that we will stop
sending our hard-earned tax dollars to
countries that don't deserve it to
dictate haters it means so we would stop
sending our our jobs and overseas and
instead would would have policies that
would help our American companies right
here that means we would Revitalize
small town America everywhere because
it's small town America that's really
suffered from America last policies and
the policies that took God out of God In
Prayer out of schools and and and has
shunned people and shamed them for for
professing their faith or being proud to
pray on a football field
um or or anywhere in the classroom it
means that we would actually come
together as a nation instead of be
divided so I don't see I don't see how
this is a bad thing but it's very
threatening to the left because it will
truly put an end to the terrible things
that they're doing to our country
especially to our kids I agree I think
this is the threat to the left and I
have a little bit of a theory as to why
which we could get to maybe a little bit
later but something you hit on here is
so important because it seems to me the
biggest objection to Christian
nationalism coming from the left right
now is that
well what about people who aren't
Christian I get you know I guess if
you're not a nationalist if you don't
love America you're not a patriot then
never mind you but what about people you
know plenty of people who aren't
Christians Jews Muslims lots of
agnostics or nuns not you know not uh
not talking about Catholic religious
sisters but the nuns n-o-n-e-s they
don't really buy into religion at all or
at least they don't think that they
don't so in a in a Christian
nationalist-informed political order
what about all those people
those people are not left out at all as
a matter of fact they're equal because
as Christians we we're we're commanded
to love others as we love ourself and
there's not an identity on that we're to
love others and and if anything that's
that's not a bad thing that's a good
thing so it doesn't leave anyone out it
doesn't reject anyone
um as a matter of fact it it makes
things a lot better for for all and and
we could argue deeper and and compare
different countries and and different
religions I mean we know what it's like
in Islamic control countries where
Sharia law is the law of the land that's
a very strict law and there's no room
for Jewish people or Christians or or
anyone that is not not a Muslim that's
actually not a good thing they have laws
about that and that's where we see
severe persecutions look at countries
like China which is a completely Godless
country well actually the government is
the god right
um there's terrible person executions
that happen there in China especially to
Christians and Muslims and and and
people that are not obedient to the
Chinese Communist party uh and the
government controlling everything so we
could we could compare different
countries and and their different way of
doing things or their different
religions but in America you know we
were founded by very strong Christians
these were men of faith and it was their
faith that drove them to to write the
Declaration of Independence and to
sacrifice their lives their families and
their fortunes so that we could all have
freedoms you know one of the greatest
things uh that we believe as Christians
is there's no greater love than this and
that is to lay down your life for
another and and that's the type of
people we are being Christians so the
left is extremely threatened by a an
idea of Christian nationalism because
they know they cannot win they cannot
beat it it defies everything that they
are and It ultimately comes down to some
very key important things Michael it's
the fact that we we refuse we refuse to
Bow and give in on on God's creation
which is God created us and male and
female and In His Image he created us
that's a fundamental Truth uh the other
truth is this is that God created life
in the womb and being being pro-life is
not hateful towards women it's actually
loving towards women and and it's
protecting life so being being a
Christian is is believing those things
and wanting to make
um just to make society and and and life
much better for everyone as well as
putting our country first and I believe
we need to do that we haven't put our
country first in decades a very very
long time and our our country is
crumbling we as a matter of fact I don't
know how we're still making it you know
we have a government that is
the Democrats and and a lot of my
Republican colleagues are driving hard
into this war in Ukraine they're
fighting a proxy war with Russia and
Russia is a nuclear Country and this is
this is hurting the entire world it's
creating food famines it's CR it's
driving inflation that already existed
from the out of control policies here in
Washington it's it's also driving the
energy prices and it's strengthening
Russia it's not hurting them while
they're making deals with other
countries like India Saudi Arabia China
and so forth but this is the kind of
America last policies that come from The
Establishment or we can call it the uni
party here in Washington that serves
Americans not at all it serves us less
it puts Americans last and people are
sick and tired of it so this isn't a
threat
um threat to globalism but it's but it
is it's the greatest thing that could
happen for our country this I think is
really why the left is so hyper focused
on making a boogeyman out of Christian
nationalism right now
what is the opposite of nationalism the
opposite of nationalism in our current
world political order is globalism and
what is the opposite of leftism well the
opposite of leftism is Christianity the
very term the left as we think about it
comes from the French Revolution it
comes from the people who sat on the
left of the National Assembly those were
the people who opposed the church who
opposed Christianity in France they were
the leftists they were the very first
leftists and so the the opposite of
Christian nationalism seems pretty
clearly to me is leftist globalism and
that's that's what they're after that's
what they've been pushing for many
decades now and so when you see such a
precise threat to that something with
that very name Christian nationalism you
could see how how they would freak out
and make a make a big stink about this
and try to misinterpret it or
misrepresent it but but I think you've
you know you've explained it quite fully
what you mean by this term Christian
nationalism what a lot of other people
mean the other aspect of this that I'm
I'm sure you're seeing in Washington is
if you're afraid of a Christian country
just wait until you see a non-Christian
country if you you know absolutely
everybody seems to have some kind of
religion the idea that we're
transgendering eight-year-olds now and
pretending that the soul has nothing to
do with the body and a toddler should go
to drag queen's Story Hour these are
moral and religious claims they just
ain't Christian and I tell you if you
offer me those two things the great drag
queen Story Hour for two-year-olds or a
Christian Society I think everybody
really regardless of your background or
even your particular religious practice
you're going to choose the Christian
Society right
oh abs of course of course they will
because let's look at what the left is
doing and I call them the Godless left
because they are Godless any any group
of people any kind of movement any kind
of political order that that is believes
in using our tax dollars and they've
done this through grants using Americans
hard-earned tax dollars to to perform
mastectomies to cash straight to
castrate teenage boys or younger to
provide testosterone treatment for girls
as young as eight years old this is evil
it's completely evil children need to be
protected they need to be allowed to
grow up they don't need to be
brainwashed into these these type of
lies that is so evil any type of
um political movement or group that that
is constantly lying to women and trying
to tell them that killing the unborn
baby in their womb is Women's Health
Care is such an it's such an evil lie
I'm telling them that they should pursue
a career where they end up childless
later on in life and maybe never get
married that that is so awful that is a
destructive but let's look at them even
further this is the this the same group
of people the Democrats or the left will
just go with the the left that that
forced everyone to take a vaccine Force
everyone to be masked Force everyone to
stay inside we're suicides increased
um crime has gone out of control people
are taking more antidepressants and and
ssris than they ever have in history and
this isn't this isn't a party or an
ideology the left doesn't care about
people they don't care about people as a
matter of fact everything they're doing
is destructive it's destructive to
people but Christian nationalism is not
destructive not at all in in a in a
Christian nationalist Society this is
where people are are cared about they're
protected they're helped this is where
we provide shelter for the the homeless
we provide we provide food for the
hungry we provide clothes for those that
don't have any we provide skills and
training for people that need to learn
how to get a job and just like pregnancy
Women's Pregnancy Resource Center
centers this is where we provide women
with help when they became pregnant and
and didn't plan to this is this is the
kind of
people we are in Christian nationalists
is is not the boogeyman it's it's not
what they're trying to make it out to be
but it is the greatest threat and you
know what I think we live in a time
right now Michael where people need God
more than ever more than ever we have we
have young people especially young women
that that look to ideas and look at
themselves in a way they never should
they don't they don't recognize the real
Beauty uh that they have inside of them
and that they are and they strive to be
something that they're not we have young
men uh men in our society
are basically last on the list when our
boys are told to sit still in school and
they're not appreciated for who they are
uh men are told they they have to wait
their turn and let everyone and every
other identity go first before they ever
get a chance and I believe that's
completely wrong and then they try to
tell men that their masculinity is toxic
and I believe that is completely wrong
uh we're living in a time where our our
unique uh separate
um identities as men and women
is totally abandoned where women the
good thing about us is we are nurturing
and and we are caring and we have these
great roles and then men also are
leaders and are strong and and women
need that for men and these these great
unique
um identities in men and women are not
appreciated anymore and not celebrated
we're living in a time where more
marriages uh end in divorce and then
make it right and that's tragic it's
tragic for everyone so
um yeah Christian nationalism is
probably the scariest thing that the
left has ever heard of and they're going
to do everything they can to lie to
everyone and make it out to something
that's not well even just that point you
mentioned more Americans than ever on
anti-depression drugs I think the number
is one in eight Americans are on the
anti-depression drugs even among
teenagers 12 to 19 years old it's
something like 1 in 29 you're seeing the
American life expectancy decrease now
several years in a row first time ever
and the reason for that is that you have
deaths of Despair suicides drug
overdoses so obviously just just from a
descriptive point of view
the kids are not all right people are
sad or they're they're in in Despair and
so you need some kind of hopes clearly
we're not going in the right direction
when you say people want God it reminds
me of that scene going all the way back
to the Cold War right toward the end of
the Cold War Pope John Paul II shows up
in Poland Poland had been under the
thumb of the Godless regime of the
Soviet of the Soviet Union Soviet
communism for years Pope John Paul II
shows up to do an open-air Mass to
celebrate the mass and millions of polls
come out there and they chant we want
God we want God it's one of the most
incredible sites of the 20th century now
my question for you before I let you go
I know I'm already keeping you late my
question for you is you're you keep
coming back to this religious point and
I think it's an important one as the
great political philosopher Bob Dylan
said everybody's got to serve somebody
you always have to have some kind of
religious views informing your politics
all politics ultimately is theological
because because you're making decisions
about what's good and bad and right and
wrong whether we're talking about the
criminal justice system whether we're
talking about parking tickets you're
always making these moral distinctions
that's what politics is so so my
question for you then is with these
Rising numbers of people who are
agnostic who are leaving churches who
are leaving who are leaving other
religions for that matter too it's not
just Christianity who are turning away
from God do you think that that we want
God is a winning political message or do
you think that the kind of forces of
secularism atheism despair do you think
that those are on the rise
well I think I think the message of we
want God or people's yearning yearning
for God is is far more than a political
message it couldn't even be defined that
way because God can't be defined that
way I think it is the the connection
between Mankind and our Creator God that
can never ever be separated and in the
dark days that we are living in I mean
we are living in times where I know you
and I both and so many people never
thought that we could could see a day
where everything that is right is is
labeled wrong and and the world is
upside down and where lies are just
openly told uh openly told and presented
as truth and this is this is such evil
and it's in evil times is this where
people yearn that connection with with
their creator our Creator God and it's
Unstoppable it is absolutely Unstoppable
and God yearns back for that
relationship with us and so my my full
belief is this Michael is if we're
Christians we are told you know we're a
light and we are not to put a shade over
it and we're not to cover it up it's to
be up on a Hilltop and to be to be shown
brightly it doesn't mean that we're
perfect and it doesn't mean that we
should be judgmental of others it
doesn't mean that um the even that we're
always right sometimes in our thinking
but it does mean that we we have a a
duty and and a commandment and we have
to be obedient to what we're told to do
and that is to share our faith with
others especially in times like this
because people need it people need to
know that they are loved by God and and
that all that's happening to them now
and and maybe what they're seeing happen
in their lives that that's not what God
intended for them and he loves them far
more than that and he sent his son uh to
die so that their sins could be forgiven
so they're there's relationship there
and to have communion and Community with
one another these are all wonderful
things and we should talk about them and
we should talk about them boldly we
should never back down off of it we
should be courageous in our faith and we
should persevere on no matter what the
Godless line left says about people like
us you know people like me I'm tired of
being attacked that's why I'm just wide
open about it I'm also not going to back
down I'm attacked every day because I
say no there's only two genders you know
I'm attacked in my office building I'm
attacked uh where they try to say it's a
hate crime for me to say stuff like that
well I believe it's a hate crime what
they're doing is lying about gender and
what they're doing to children that is
those are hate crimes and so I believe
it's it's fundamental for us to to be
loving and kind to one another but it's
also extremely important to stop
allowing the lines to be blurred truth
is truth and we have to we have to fight
for it and hold on to it like I I like
your observation I mean this is
something that Christian thinkers have
known but even non-Christian thinkers
have understood that man has a natural
longing for God that is true in all
places at all times throughout all of
history and uh there and then there is a
kind of political implication to this
too which is uh for most vast majority
of American History we have viewed
politics through a Christian lens
through the lens of a Christian moral
framework through the lens of
Christianity broadly going back all the
way to the pilgrims on the Mayflower and
all the way up until very recent decades
in recent decades there has been a
concerted effort by leftist radicals to
upend all of that and if you if you
judge the tree by its fruit you look at
the fruit of what that cultural
revolution has caused people are not
flourishing in the way they once were
people or more miserable people are more
despondent the country is is really not
better off because of that radical
ideology so maybe it's time to revisit a
little bit of the wisdom of the past and
the things that have made America great
in the past hopefully they can again
congresswoman green thank you so much
for coming on the show very much
appreciate it
thank you Michael I enjoyed it
[Music]
[Music]